und sie
stücke mit davon gekommen immerhin
[Musik]
gibt es nur wenn es bis dahin
sie wollen auf und davon birgitt und
jürgen haben kinder großgezogen jetzt
ziehen sie los auf die philippinen
die familie fischer aus dem aargau
wünscht sich mehr lebensqualität
sie bricht auf in die weite kanadas
von appenzell ans mittelmeer monika und
bert daniela folgen ihren traum sie
bauen ein kleines hotel in der türkei
[Musik]
dem türkischen aller theater ist das
hotel fertig gebaut endlich und es hat
einen namen la vela zu deutsch das segel
in die freude mischt sich
abschiedsschmerz rosa monika und bernd
gans tröster arbeiter hat seinen letzten
arbeitstag
[Musik]
damit du dich an uns erinnert das habe
ich für dich gemacht mit den buchstaben
r wie danke
du kannst es als schlüsselanhänger
benutzen ich hätte monika fast einmal in
solchen anhänger gebeten jetzt hat sie
selber daran gedacht
danke für alles
ich küsse dich auch so
danke für alles ich werde dich nie
vergessen und du bist jederzeit bei uns
willkommen
[Musik]
vor ihm liegt eine 20 stündige autofahrt
tief im osten der türkei warten seine
frau und seine kleine tochter auf ihn
über ein halbes jahr hat rosa seiner
familie kaum gesehen
[Musik]
natürlich sehr traurig wegen wir ja muss
so abschied nehme ich sie bemängelt tag
vertagt und weniger bis krise hätte
eigentlich immer cool für die neuen
gebäude kabinen liebe stock sie wir den
ruf erarbeitet auch sie sind also ich
sag ja ich schwierig zum beschrieben
was auf dich auf
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
kam der hotelbau nur zögerlich voran
wegen der
zwischenfälle behinderten die arbeiten
doch es gab auch schöne momente
denn ein olivenbaum im garten so heißt
es bringe glück
während die ochsen allein auf palawan
war ließ sich birgit in der schweiz
untersuchen diagnose die
lähmungserscheinungen in ihren füßen
sind auf mangelernährung zurückzuführen
wegen einer magen bypass operation hatte
birgit zu schnell abgenommen zurück auf
palawan ging es ihr dank
aufbaupräparaten bald wieder besser
in kanada errichtete zimmermann kurt
fischer sein erstes blockhaus und
annett brachte pauli das schulbus fahren
bei
[Musik]
jahrelang hat bert daniela davon
geträumt nun ist der traum wirklichkeit
geworden er ist besitzer eines schmucken
hotels samt swimmingpool
endlich werden wir eröffnen da machen
wir ganz viel freude
und wir erwarten natürlich auch fehler
gäste das werde alle zimmer voll kriegen
das ist unsere ziel
das ist keine algen
platz bringen hier deswegen muss man
einen
stein zu zweifeln mit der bürste und
immer zum einen weg nicht hin und her
sondern immer von außen nach innen zum
pool
monika die gelernte schneiderin nicht
noch vorhänge für die gästezimmer
eigentlich hätten sie bereits vor zwei
monaten eröffnen wollen doch sie konnten
ihren fahrplan nicht einhalten
es ist so schwierig sie sind so
vielseitig aufgelaufen dann immer leid
waren machen joachim riester thema
normales level kreis sich als kriegs sie
kein stress mit bau liegt mit
irgendwelchen sage mit dem geld kann ich
da eigentlich animierter leichte sich
einfach ganz sicher geeignet zum
normales leben und daher absolut nicht
mehr risiko fürs kino
und barocke bis wo sie kann ihn einfach
wird sie und rom häufig oder sogar und
nur ein paar kleinigkeiten noch
kleinigkeiten die perfekt werden sollen
die auswanderer haben hohe ansprüche
für diese nehmen sie sogar finanzielle
einbußen in kauf
speziell und wenn ich
fertig ist und alles wird noch immer mit
dem knappen sieg rundet willen
jugendlichen
ein tag oder nach wo man immer wieder
rat der sich den wirklich perfekt
unternehmen
ich bin gern späteren malkovich und
jamaika
[Musik]
noch ist es nachtschwarz am schwab lake
doch schon sind die zimmermänner auf den
beinen
trotz der harten und langen arbeitstage
ist es für kurt fischer ein traumjob mit
massivem holz und viel muskelkraft kann
der schweizer hier großes
[Musik]
über 100 baumstämme braucht es für
dieses luxuriöse blockhaus holz aus
kanadischen zedern wovon einige mehrere
hundert jahre alt sind
[Musik]
400 kilometer nördlich befindet sich
kurz eigenes traumhaus der neue wohnsitz
der familie fischer
hier steht zum pauli vor einer großen
feuerprobe heute fährt er zum ersten mal
alleine mit dem bus zur schule
nicht witzig
[Gelächter]
ein paar minuten später fährt auch
mutter annett zur schule sicher ist
sicher
ich habe mich hier gut gefallen doch
ruhig
auf dem parkplatz ist pauli nicht zu
sehen
[Musik]
auch auf dem weiträumigen pausenplatz
keine spur von paul ii
[Musik]
wir haben sie paul gesehen nein habe ich
nicht ich weiß nicht wo er ist
vielleicht ist er im schulbus geblieben
ist der hineingekommen
am besten gehen sie zu herrn williams
wo ist herr williams normalerweise ist
er bei den schulbussen
sollte herr williams der rektor der
schule auch nicht wissen wo paul ist
muss sich annett ernsthaft sorgen machen
[Musik]
nach einem jahr bauzeit ist das jungle
beach resort dessert passen nun eröffnet
das geschäft ist gut angelaufen
jörg der einstige informatiker wächst
jeden tag mehr in die rolle des
gastgebers hinein
etwas allerdings hat dirk nicht mehr im
angebot
ich bin auch gips tragen
schnell hat sich herumgesprochen dass es
in jungle beat ein besonders
reichhaltiges frühstück gibt
nun darf mit dem segen der behörde
gebadet werden die offiziellen
baderegeln sind wie vorgeschrieben
angebracht
selbst der hochsitz für den bademeister
steht
gold wird der leidenschaftliche taucher
jörg seine gäste auch unterwasser
begleiten können er lässt sich zum
master auswegen
tauchausrüstungen vermieten sie bereits
und so muss es drückt
das zieht natürlich länger auf post
sondern
die getippe ist vorbei
so groß so
kann ich noch birgt die haut es auch
schon gehabt hatte es in riga wisse
jeder tag verzug da
werden milliarden
maschine unter 40 ausrutscher
birgit hat innerhalb eines jahres 60
kilogramm abgenommen
kurz vor ihrer auswanderung ließ sie
sich einen magenbypass legen aus
gesundheitlichen gründen
die ehemalige schulleiterin ist nur noch
halb so schwer wie früher durch diesen
wandel hat sich bei birgit nicht nur das
gewicht verändert
er wird nicht nur dünner wird aber mit
denen heutiger also das blatt nimmer so
alles reimer oder ja na also man hat
einfach nicht mehr so die schutzschicht
und mich jetzt irgendwie
okay ich musste ich sage ich würde jetzt
wird es nochmal machen und ich bin
eigentlich
traurig dass ich vorher gemacht haben
will ich hätte es nicht dass nabucco
[Musik]
in der türkei ist die sommersaison in
voller blüte sonnenhungrige badenixen
und wassersportler
genießen das ägäische meer
[Musik]
zahlreiche touristen tummeln sich trotz
der mittagshitze in zentrum von al assad
jetzt wäre die zeit gekommen um geld zu
verdienen
doch im hotel la vela ist die
eingangstüre verschlossen und alle neun
zimmer stehen leer trotz hochsaison
haben monika und bernd an ihr hotel noch
immer nicht eröffnet es geht um details
die barhocker haben noch nicht den
richtigen anstrich und noch eine
kleinigkeit fehlt
der japan hast du einen pinsel
pass auf deine kleider auf
gekommen
in der hotellobby steht ein pärchen
guten tag sind wir die ersten gäste ja
ja aber mein mann ist türke
möchten sie ein großes oder kleines
zimmer
ich zeige ihnen gerne die zimmer
überrascht und ein wenig unvorbereitet
monika zeigt zum ersten mal ihre
gästezimmer
das ist für zwei personen mit balkon
schön
sehr schön
dieses thema hatte einen französischen
balkon
ich zeige ihnen einfach alles und dann
können sie entscheiden
[Musik]
das ist das größte zimmer
und es hat einen großen balkon
danke wirklich ist ja wirklich
sich so pro jahr womit sie nicht
vorbereitet ja dann nicht mehr dabei
denkt dass via stream was mich damals
mit disney cruise
das paar ist vom charme der zimmer
angetan und bleibt schnell organisiert
monika den zimmerschlüssel ihr maler der
hilfe springt für berta nein und kümmert
sich um die formalitäten
einen olivenbaum haben die auswanderer
gepflanzt damit ihnen das glück bei
steht hunderte von arbeitsstunden
mussten sie in ihr hotel investieren
schweiß und auch einige tränen hat ihnen
der bau abverlangt nun sind sie da die
ersten gäste von vielen die noch kommen
sollen
es ist immer noch nicht fertig ich
dachte ihr habt schon fertig ja
mir immer dass er fertig mache sehr
stinkt uns sehr gut man freut sich
man freut sich
und gefühl gefühl wie ist deine gefühl
endlich gut aber doch eine gefühlte
schlüssel kann nimmt
auf den kufen begrenzt gleich werde
darauf geachtet immer mal kontrollieren
monika und burtons neues leben als
gastgeber hat begonnen
[Musik]
in kanada sucht eine besorgte annett
noch immer ihren paul ii
guten morgen haben sie vielleicht paul
gesehen
mich hier sein
[Musik]
vielleicht ist dem schulbus geblieben
imbiss gebilden ich weiß nicht
jedenfalls ist er nicht da
lasst uns die busfahrerin anrufen
ich suche ein erstklässler der
vielleicht im bus geblieben ist kannst
du mal nachschauen
ist ein neuer schüler
ich
danke
er ist im busdepot
liebt eben mit dem schulbus zu fahren wo
ist das busdepot
das passiert wirklich sind
speziell
das ist anders und will schnellstmöglich
zu paul ii denn der sechsjährige spricht
noch kein englisch und weiß sich deshalb
nicht zu helfen
ist ok er ist nur sehr traurig
die busfahrerin hatten unter dem sitz
nicht gesehen
[Musik]
augsburg
ok
[Musik]
das jungle beach resort ist seit zwei
wochen eröffnet alle bungalows sind
belegt außerdem kleinen backpacker
häuschen nun hat sich eine fünfköpfige
familie angekündigt
[Musik]
kurzerhand räumen die sands ihr eigenes
großes haus um in das kleine häuschen
für rucksackreisende umzuziehen
[Musik]
das loch graben und wurde jetzt also im
kostenlosen gift streue
sprich mir mühsam rasch ja das ist also
wirklich in the jungle also musik
gesprungen person oder verschlucken und
vertreten
ich weiß seit ich mache da irgendwie so
eine schau
also ich finds grus grus nein dort der
frosch und toten frosch hat sicherlich
auch zur braucht dafür ein die ziemlich
dick straße
lebt diesen traum sind die
tarifautonomie
nicht so viel
das backpacker häuschen ist der
einfachste und günstigste bungalowanlage
25 franken kostet die nacht frühstück
inklusive
bald zieht sich
durch alle branchen ist also vor der
schlüssigkeit haben ist lieblingslied
dauer soll also einfach da
sind doppelwandig oder rudiment bei
gc schon aus ständig sagt sie hat sie
gut also dass ist birgit webseiten mit
einem neuen einheitsmotoren kartusche da
habe ich jetzt gefunden ausgebucht ist
das neue aber ja
[Musik]
nach umwegen kommt pauli schließlich
doch noch bei der schule an trotz des
schreckens wer den unterricht nicht
verpassen
tapfer hat er sein erstes großes
abenteuer in der neuen heimat
überstanden als ob nichts gewesen wäre
setzt er sich an seinen platz
[Musik]
hast du eine lange busfahrt gemacht
weit weg auf montage weiß kurt fischer
nichts vom kleinen drama um seinen sohn
seine aufmerksamkeit gilt einem bären
hoch in der luft
[Musik]
da
der bär ist aus massivem holz geschnitzt
und wiegt 200 kilogramm
[Musik]
solche tierischen verzierungen sind eine
spezialität von kurz firma
in einer kurzen pause ruft kurz seine
frau annett an
[Musik]
während der hochsaison verwandelt sich
das zentrum von al assad der jeden abend
zu einer pulsierenden ausgangs meile
nur wenige gehminuten entfernt im hotel
ávila herrscht freude und erleichterung
die ersten gäste sind da und das obwohl
monika und berta ihr hotel eigentlich
noch nicht eröffnet haben
ein verheißungsvolles zeichen und grund
genug um mit den angestellten anzustoßen
wir haben etwas schönes
schon zum welt gebracht das ist wie eine
kinder geburt gewesen für uns beide wir
haben hier keine kinder kriegen immer
fang ich da wirklich
hier könnte sie mit dreck und stein und
wie es langsam immer wachsen und wachsen
nicht und vor allem am schluss wo die
gartenpflege machte pool was ich alles
wunderbar und in dem moment wo alles
fertig mit sabine hämmer der piste und
dem was durchgestanden der karte und
zum auto du hast schon
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
auf palawan will jörg für birgit den
ofen ein fan
der serie hast du einen leeren karton
doch die angestellte desiree hat keine
zeit eierkartons aufzutreiben sie zeigt
einer neuen putzfrau wie die bungalows
sauber gemacht werden müssen
anfänglich hatte der serie das ehepaar
sind geradezu bemuttert nun gilt ihre
ganze aufmerksamkeit dem betrieb die
bungalows sollen stets sauber und
gepflegt sein
das resort besteht aus vier bungalows
mit preisen zwischen 25 und 90 franken
pro nacht
das größte und luxuriöseste haus ist das
paradise haus
es verfügt über zwei schlafzimmer eine
klimaanlage und mitten auf der terrasse
über einen kleinen whirlpool
jörg muss sich selber helfen
statt mit eierkartons versucht er mit
trockenen palmwedeln und bier kartons
das feuer zu entfachen
hier geht noch brot genau noch zwei
droht
bis jetzt haben wir das brot oder
aufhöre wenn man also auch geliebt hat
und in den buchungsprozess
birgit bereit den job teig vor ein gast
aus der schweiz hilft ihr dabei
mein name wurde rapid und ich denen
sagen
dass
sich die augen
es gibt also leute mit extra
frau
als besitzerin eines ferienresorts
begegnet birgit vielen menschen
allerdings sind diese beziehungen häufig
oberflächlicher natur
die soziale kontakt
mir am meisten
dass man mit gerade wo ein verstehen
dass also inhaltlich und
inhaltlich und sprachlich das ist das
sehr schwierig also wann ist erläutert
oder wollen sind das meistens man mit
ihnen philippinische frauen und dann
trifft man sich und dann sind die
philippinische frauen zusammen und redet
gelockt und dann sind die russland die
redet ihr meistens dann englisch wie es
ja durchaus verschiedene nationen und
wenn ich dann alles gerne und das bin
ich und das sitzt
die philippinische frau eigentlich
spielen
und wartet das derby ist das ist das ist
doch lidia die geschichte wirklich
schwierig ist als europäische oder
ausländische frau darwin das gibt es
einfach vor schweden
ja also darum bin ich habe dann auf
homegate also wo der schweiz kümmert und
dennoch konnte ich mich mit denen
unterhalten
komme ich aus duschen und so
ich denke ich werde alle zwölf minuten
sie will da fällt mir jetzt viel viel
ich werde es nie drüben auch an inventar
und dann war da
noch nie habe die mir nicht hin zur mini
wirklich gelebt job und nach und den
korridor bietet
kroschke sie und mit
haben sie
mir doch sehr fehlen oder
bei gewissen dingen die sie vermisst wie
zopf oder brot weiß sich birgit mit
einem eigenen rezept zu helfen
schwieriger wird es wenn es um gute
freunde geht das ehepaar sender deshalb
eine abmachung getroffen während birgit
ab und zu in die schweiz fliegt herr
görg das ganze jahr über die stellung im
resort
[Musik]
nun klappt es heute steigt an der
richtigen haltestelle aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wurde im schulbus als florist und so
nachhaltig der name der pflicht sonst
bin ich
also so was passiert schon nichts so
viel wie du willy brandt ihnen ja quasi
nur die möglichkeit dass sie jetzt
nächsten
schulbusse und können sich meine frau
nie passiert oder da jetzt kaufen
[Musik]
im hotel la vela gönnen sich die einen
gäste ein morgendliches bad während es
sich die anderen auf der veranda
gemütlich machen
guten morgen wie geht es nach uns geht
es gut haben sie sich etwas erholt sie
waren bestimmt sehr erschöpft doch
es ist wirklich schön geworden
danke danke
monika bereitet ihr allererstes
frühstück für hotelgäste vor der
angestellte abdou hilft dir dabei
ebenfalls zum ersten mal tischen sie
jenes geschirr auf dessentwegen sich
monika und per tan vor monaten heftig
gestritten hatten
doch diese streitereien sind lange
vergessen
murat kannst du bitte behilflich sein
die auswanderer haben die feuerprobe als
hoteliers bestanden ihre ersten gäste
scheinen sich wohl gefühlt zu haben
man verabschiedet sich freundschaftlich
modica und wärtern haben grund zur
hoffnung dass das paar das hotel weiter
empfiehlt
jahre lang trugen monika und wärtern den
traum des eigenen hotels in ihren herzen
sie haben alle ihre kraft und alle ihre
finanziellen mittel in dieses projekt
gesteckt
der bau war auch eine bewährungsprobe
für ihre liebe heute wissen sie dass sie
als paar nichts umwerfen kann auch wenn
die anstrengende zeit ihre spuren
hinterlassen hat
[Musik]
in kanada ist die familie fischer wieder
glücklich vereint
[Musik]
nach zwei wochen auf montage ist kurz
wieder bei seiner familie
zeit um gemeinsam zu musizieren und
darüber nachzudenken was man in den
letzten monaten alles vollbracht hat
seehofer ist das register großes ziel
gesteckt hat und mehr an mir ganz
erreicht und
mit wendigkeit aber vielleicht nicht
ganz mit einem sehen sehen wo sie seit
er sie aber mehr ans ziel erreicht und
als gut und jetzt kommt reset ihn erste
ziel stecken und logica mussten wir es
wieder
machen im wald hinter räumlich schüttler
das auto an und so strom das
[Musik]
aufdrucke motor fahrspur
kuschelbär
raum weite und ruhe hat die familie
fischer in kanada gesucht das alles
findet sie nun direkt vor ihrer haustüre
[Musik]
das meer ist bewegt bewegt wie die
letzten monate des er passen aus dem
zürcherischen opfikon
seit 30 jahren sind die sens ein paar
sie haben kinder großgezogen und schon
einige unwägbarkeiten des lebens
gemeistert ihr jüngstes abenteuer
fordert sie wieder von neuem und
verlangt unkonventionelle lösungen drei
monate im jahr zieht es birgit in die
schweiz zurück
klingt das ist
die lehre bietet ich danke
meinem viel
mit
stolz über das erreichte verbindet die
beiden
auf dem fischerboot schauen sie sich von
weit draußen ihr neues zuhause unter
palmen an
hast du nicht sind auch begeistert
verwendet haben
die weniger wohnungslosigkeit betrieben
was man jetzt noch und schlimmen ist die
ganze geschichte begann zwar aber noch
nie so überfordert dass jemand gemüses
aufgenommen das muss ich sagen das sage
ich hätte viele biene und crew musste
schweizer aber das ist zum teil schon
einfach wenn man sich sehr gründlich
alles ist auf dem tisch
beherzt und glauben auch an
mit über 50 waren die fans bereit
nochmals zu anfängern zu werden sie
gaben alte sicherheiten auf und folgten
ihrer sehnsucht der sehnsucht nach einem
kleinen paradies am meer unter palmen
[Musik]
auswanderer geschichten sind geschichten
von menschen die ihr schicksal in die
eigenen hände nehmen und ihr leben nicht
auf den nächsten tag verschieben
im wissen dass man nur ein leben hat
sind sie bereit alles aufzugeben um ihre
träume zu verwirklichen
[Musik]
liga live
das kam an
schüler die aus
[Musik]
das
[Applaus]
[Musik]